[Music]
[Music]
you
alright guys we are live on the YouTube
today I haven't done a live stream in a
couple weeks last one was with Jordan
Peterson I think that was about two
three weeks ago so I just want to do a
check-in I want to do a little ask me
anything I wanted to catch you guys up
on a couple interesting things going on
with the show and with my world and all
that I just had a really really
enjoyable conversation with Antonia
Okafor if you don't know her she's a
she's a big Second Amendment advocate
she's a campus carry advocate and we had
a really interesting discussion about
what it's like to be a female black
conservative from Texas and about guns
and about abortion and all kinds of
stuff that should be up in about a week
or so later today I'm interviewing Rabbi
David Wolpe who is the rabbi at Sinai
temple here in Los Angeles we're going
to talk some existential stuff and
meaning a life and all kinds of other
interesting things but I did want to
give a chance for you guys to do a
little ask me anything because we
haven't done one of these in a while so
we did post this on patreon so if you
are a patron patronage has its rewards
and you will get first access to the
questions so I know people have already
started to ask some questions right
there and then because you know the
youtube comment section is just madness
especially during live streams Loveall
yeah god bless yeah
we are enabling super chat right now so
you know if you throw in a couple bucks
it bumps the chat up and I'm able to see
it my guys send it to me on my trusty
iPad right here and we'll we'll talk
about anything it doesn't have to be
just politics obviously there's a lot
going on at the moment between Trump's
travels to Saudi Arabia and to Israel
everything that happened in Manchester
yesterday which I'm going to spend a
bunch of time on shortly and then just
general other craziness so first I want
to talk a little bit about about what
happened in Manchester now obviously
this this is unfolding at the moment and
what I found yesterday you know I think
I'm finding this more and more and I'm
probably not the only one that being on
social media and especially Twitter
because that's where you're just getting
this endless feed of information so it's
a little bit different than Facebook
where the feed is and as uncontrolled
you know by time and there's an
algorithm that's putting stuff in your
feed and all that that Twitter this
endless straw
of this is half-truths not truth fake
news this is true this is retracted by a
reputable news organization this is a
news organization nobody's ever heard of
but everybody's retweeting all of this
like breaking need for all of us to get
in on the story and by the way I get I
succumbed to that myself sometimes I
really really tried not to yesterday
it's just making it's just making so
much noise and then the immediate people
that start fighting about things and
start attacking each other and all this
craziest it doesn't really help for any
of the real conversation which as you
guys know is what I've been trying to do
around here so I want to just catch you
up on a couple a couple points we bullet
it out some points that we know
basically about Manchester right now so
if you're watching this and you're
watching the news and you can't really
figure out what's going on or you're
reading news sources that you're not
really sure all right this is what we
know to be true right now most of this
is from the BBC but a mirror compiled a
bunch of things for me and again we'll
talk about it for a little bit and I
will do some QA and a bunch of other
stuff so obviously as you all know at
this point what happened yesterday was
at the ariana grande concert in
Manchester and there was a terrorist
attack at the moment it looks like 22
people have been killed and it injured
at least 59 people there's 12 of the 16
that are among the injured oh no I'm
sorry 12 under the age of 16 are among
the injured so this is really to attack
an area on a ground a concert I mean
this is a place where young kids a lot
of young girls go maybe with their
parents for the first time that they're
going to a concert saying I mean this
was a direct attack on young people
which does in a weird way make it worse
only three of the victims have been
identified at this point the youngest
one so far is 8 years old 8 years old
just try to take that in for just a
second there's a lot of people that are
missing and unaccounted for police have
named Salman Abadi as the as the
suspected suicide bomber so there's some
questions as to whether it was a suicide
bomb or some other bomb that he placed I
think they're going to try to work that
out but that seems like they're going
with suicide bombers oh and it sounds
like there may have been nails placed in
the bomb which has been done in other
cases of suicide bombing
he's Manchester born and from Libyan
origin they do believe he blew himself
up in the foyer there at about 11:30
p.m. as people were leaving the concert
so that led leads you to believe that
there was definitely some sort of
premeditated I want to kill as many
people as possible Shh skip some of this
there's also another 23 year-old man in
South Manchester who's been arrested
possibly confirmed and if if this is a
terrorist attack which all evidence
points to it being it would be the worst
terrorist attack in the UK since 52
people were killed in the London
bombings which were in July of 2005 and
on the positive note because there is
some positivity around this because I
think the human spirit actually is quite
good and wants to do good
Manchester itself I mean there's been a
ton of outpouring the blood banks are
beyond full quote full to the rafters
there's about 200 taxi drivers out there
that I think have been waving fares and
letting people they're driving people
and driving food and victims and water
all around the city so the the city is
coming together itself so that that
that's basically the what do we know at
this point and the reason I wanted to do
it that way is because if you're feeling
that you're having trouble get to
ciphering what is sort of real in the
news these days I'm feeling the same
thing and I don't think social media is
helping in this regard and as I said
before I sometimes get lost in that too
and sometimes you jump the gun or
whatever I'm going to do my best not to
do that with this or with anything else
in the future I tweeted out a couple
things this morning that were more sort
of broad broad philosophical takes on it
not not the specifics of it alright so
let's let's knock out some some
questions I'll start with patreon what
is the appropriate classical liberal
response to terrorism I mean this is a
great question it's a good meaty one for
me to start off here now I don't know
that every political ideology if you're
going to look at progressives classical
liberals
you know conservatives libertarians that
I don't think they all sort of have this
definitive definition of how do you
fight terrorism but liberalism which is
based in logic and reason classical
liberalism I say this all time but
Google what it is okay read a little
John Stuart Mill it's based in logic and
reason so the most important thing that
you could do in any response is to
understand what the threat is now this
is what people like assuming we're
talking about this being a radical
Islamic tack which it seems like it is
this is what people like Sam Harris and
Maajid Nawaz and Bill Maher and ayaan
Hirsi Ali and many others and Brigitte
Gabriel who's just sitting here this is
what these people have been talking
about that we have to understand what
the threat is not because of bigotry or
because of racism or a rush to judgment
or for some easy answer but we have to
actually understand what is the doctrine
that these people are following to get
into the afterlife where they view that
world as better than this world
what causes people to do this are their
geopolitical reasons that people get
involved also is it because of poverty
and all of these things I think you know
most of my feelings on this stuff and
there's most evidence to say that this
is a religious thing I mean you only
have to read Isis's magazine they've got
a magazine to know that there's a
religious underpinning they tell you why
they're doing this we often find that
these the the people that commit the
suicide bombings and other terrorist
acts that they aren't poor or in poverty
and all kinds of other things the 9/11
hijackers for example we're not so the
best classical liberal response would be
to have an honest discussion about the
issues now this is something that we do
terribly here it's something that I try
to do in this room but you know if you
look at the election you had Hillary
Clinton who refused to really say the
phrase radical Islamic terror or
whatever phrase you wanted her to say
about it she just kind of refused to and
then Trump who was more than happy to
say it now oddly in the last couple days
inside everybody he backed off that
phrase a little bit I thought his speech
there was actually pretty good and I'm
happy to talk about that a little bit
but my point is that you we had these
sort of two polarizing things one
wouldn't address the problem for fear of
being called a bigot or a
sister whatever it was or because of
just pure pandering or oppression
Olympics nonsense and the other one that
was going to give you the sort of meat
easy answer on this so we've gotta have
an honest discussion about why people
are doing this how do we defend
ourselves how do we not by invading
countries but how do we have better law
enforcement how do we have better you
know services that can either figure out
what the threats are or figure out how
to stop them when they're coming all of
those things so the classical liberal
response would be one based in logic and
reason that wouldn't be compromised by
political correctness or by just by red
meat slogans now unfortunately that
doesn't seem to be a real middle ground
that we operate in much in politically
or in the media these days but I do
believe and I know it by the numbers of
people that are that are watching this
and that contact me and that I've sort
of you know created allies with lately
that there is some good movement in this
and getting logic and reason to work is
is good all right Shh this is on super
chat where is the million peaceful
Muslim March against her that's a look
that's a good question now if you were
to ask Brigitte Gabriel who I had here
or ayaan Hirsi Ali or even Yasmin
Muhammad all wonderful women who I've
had here over the last couple weeks I
think they would argue that
unfortunately the mainstream Muslim
groups I care the council for American
Islamic reconciliation or I forget what
the R stands for that they're not
they're actively not working to do these
things they're actually trying to
obfuscate and not let people understand
that this has some connection to the
doctrines of Islam and all that other
stuff so where is that March I would
love to see that March I would be a
participant at that March if I if I was
welcome there we need more voices to
step up and that's also what we need
just from the average person that's
watching this if you're if you're afraid
I say this all the time but I think it's
as true as anything I can possibly say
if you yourself right now in 2017 are
afraid of saying something that you
to be true that you believe to be a
problem whatever it is enough to just
talk about terrorism whatever you think
is true on this earth right now if
you're afraid to say it now because
you're gonna because of what someone
might say to you or what they might call
to you or that you might lose your job
or some other whatever it is or
someone's going to defriend you on
Facebook or block you on Twitter what do
you think it's going to be like in 2025
you know what what's it going to be like
in eight years if we if we slowly let
this chip away it will not be good and
that's why I think the free speech thing
is is the it's the Nexus of all of this
stuff I've come to a place where I
really don't care what most of your
political beliefs are if we can agree on
the free speech thing if we can start
there the free speech thing which is the
the piece of a pluralistic democratic
society that we want and that we have
still hopefully for a little longer that
if we have that then we can you think
this about taxes you think that's about
abortion you think there's about that
money all right that's great that's what
great debate in a free society is all
about but if we don't have that free
speech underpinning then we really have
nothing so I would love to see a million
Muslim March or you know a lot of these
things end up they get sort of curtailed
by by interest groups and and the
message gets muddled and all that I
think generally though what I would like
to see is that I would like to see
people on the left not immediately to
make this about somehow that we're going
to offend Muslims by talking about this
stuff I didn't see any I I really I
personally didn't see anyone on Twitter
saying all muslims yesterday but we have
to be able to talk about a doctrine that
would lead people to this otherwise what
do you do you're literally not literally
you you are figuratively you're throwing
an eight-year-old girl who is dead who
went to a concert a kids concert
basically a kids concert she's dead and
you're throwing her memory under the bus
by not addressing what actually was the
problem you're throwing the dead people
at pulse nightclub in Orlando
the thirty-some-odd gay people or
friends of gay people who are dead
you're throwing them under the bus
you're throwing the women who got raped
in cologne last year after New Year's
you're throwing them under the bus and
this is what so when we talk about the
oppression Olympics this is what we're
talking about that if you were putting
these groups on top of each other well
then you're always going to be pushing
them down and you're going to be you're
going to be doing horrible things
against women against gays against
virtually all minorities in the name of
an ideology in this case that would not
be very fond of you as a progressive
okay um have you seen the hate that
Tommy Robinson is getting crazy yeah I
saw Tommy tweeting last night and he was
getting a ton of hate he retweets it and
he fights with people and things like
that
look I mentioned in my DM that I shot
this morning which will be up tomorrow
this sort of guilt by association
concept you know that I get hate because
I've talked to Milo and Paul Joseph
Watson and and Mike Serna vich and Tommy
Robinson and this guilt by association
thing is dangerous it's another
silencing technique they use these words
bigoted racist all that that silence is
people but then also that's not enough
for these people that don't want us to
have conversations then they also want
to make sure you're not going to have a
conversation with someone else cause
we're going to tar and feather them too
I'm not going to play by those rules I'm
gonna do what I consistently think is
right and talk to people that I think
are interesting and enlightening and
worth talking to regardless of that I
mean you know Colin Moriarty who is on
my show and who is dealing with some of
this stuff you know he said you cannot
give them an inch and you cannot give
these people an inch they will silence
us all and once they go all right we
have this whole group though they're not
going to talk about this well guess what
they know now they've got you by the
balls and they're going to go to move it
on to something else that we're not
allowed to talk about even you know this
is a sort of ancillary metaphor for this
or analogy but you know Bret Stevens who
was a conservative writer at the Wall
Street Journal got hired at the New York
Times and his first piece I believe was
about being skeptic of being skeptic in
general of politics had a bit to do with
climate change he did not deny climate
change but the outrage machine of the
left the so-called tolerant left
tolerant New York elite New York Times
liberals went after him demanding he'd
be fired and people were I mean people
were rioting horrible things I mean
verified people on journalists on
Twitter telling him to go [ __ ] himself
and all this stuff and what I thought
was interesting was a he wasn't denying
climate change he was just saying be
skeptical in general which I think
Albert Einstein if he was here today
would say be skeptical of everything but
that's sort of intolerance what it's
saying is all right well we can get you
let's say we're going to get you and
you're never going to talk about your
legitimate fears about Islamic extremism
well then we're net we're going to get
you and you're not gonna be able to talk
about climate change and then we'll get
you you won't be able to talk about
abortion if you're pro-life and etc set
you will keep going so we gotta pull
some of this [ __ ] back and I think we're
making some headway here but but we have
a big big fight to file if you're just
jumping in we're doing the super chat
thing and I'm taking questions on
patreon and we're talking about
Manchester we could talk a little bit
about Trump in Saudi Arabia by that that
picture of him with King Salman and Sisi
from Egypt and Trump with their hands on
that orb I mean this is weird stuff like
I saw that picture I was like that's got
to be photoshopped then you scroll for a
second you go my god
this is real it looked like the orb at
the end of that boss toss is holding at
the end of Phantom Menace you don't
think I was going to get through a live
stream without the Star Wars reference
did you not a patron one day I will what
is the best solution to Islamic terror I
think siding with moderate Muslims who
want to reform will help well look this
is this is the battle that I think is
happening within the Muslim community I
think it's happening within the skeptic
community in the atheist community and
and and for people that care for Muslim
people and that who care about secular
values and care about minorities and
this is the conversation that everybody
should be having I think in general
there's two lines of thinking here so
there's the line of thinking of someone
like Maajid Nawaz who I consider a
friend and I think he's is a very good
human being and Iran's Quilliam in the
UK and they're trying to reform Islam
from the inside so he believes and this
is a former Islamist by the way you
spend time in an Egyptian jail
this he believes that reforming Islam
from the inside using liberalism I mean
I think he describes himself as a
classical liberal that using the ideas
of live and let live liberalism is what
could reform Islam and that's how you do
it
now I've had many discussions with
people that don't think that's the right
way although there in many cases friends
with Majid but but my friend Faisal
who's been on the show many times and
Sarah Haider and Yasmin Muhammad and Ali
Rizvi Ali I suppose a little bit less I
don't to speak for everybody but the
idea being that you have to actually
leave the religion that their
Reformation is not possible so I don't
know exactly what the answer is what I
know is I will gladly ally with people
that will talk about a very difficult
topic and you know I've seen a little
infighting now within the ex Muslim
community and and the the reformer
community and it's sort of I sometimes I
see it and it's kind of disappointing
because I'm like you know guys were
we're really all on the same team here
and if you want Western values and you
want liberalism then we shouldn't be all
fighting but another way the infighting
actually shows that the movement has
grown to a point where they can start
fighting with each other and I think
that that actually that internal debate
which maybe isn't for me to be part of
that internal debate I think is good for
them so I think that's good let's see
Trump said the fight is good versus evil
not religious would you get Ravi
Zacharias on your show to discuss it I
think he phrases it better than anyone
yeah you know he's been on our master
list I don't know if we've reached out
but I'll make sure that we do do that
for sure let's see on on super chat as a
bank I'm not sure what that means I
appreciate the support of the foreign
commune Oh Oh as someone in Manchester I
think no maybe I'm not as a mank I
appreciate the support of the foreign
community but in the Philippines an
entire city Mara we has been taken by
Isis why is this being ignored by the
media I'm not sure if that's a typo or
I'm just not sure what Bank is well I
haven't heard this story which I guess
proves your point an entire city and the
Philippines has been taken by Isis I
haven't heard that and again this goes
to show that our media is just not doing
a great job our mainstream media
they're running all day with Trump
Russia stories and you're getting very
little else now they did of course cut
over to Manchester yesterday and I
suspect if you turn on all three cable
news you get them today but that's an
old-school way of getting the news and
as always in a world of the internet
don't only get your news for me I don't
consider myself a news man I certainly
hope that you don't get your only
information for me I'm trying to bring
you the facts as as honestly as I can
but it's sort of the burden now is on
you to get news however you can so I
would say to you the answer to this is
start tweeting about it you probably are
already but post about it on Facebook
get people to know about it tweet an
article about this and tag me and I'll
retweet you and hopefully we can get
some eyeballs on this but yeah the media
they don't want debut sir you know they
got to get ratings they got to get
clicks and I guess talking about Trump's
stake or whether Ivanka slapped his hand
away which it looks like she did on the
air on the tarmac in Israel he kind of
put his hand back and she kind of batted
it away and that's good for gifts and
getting people all jazzed up and all
that stuff when when seriously bad shits
going on so it's it's tough for sure uh
on on super chat when are you going to
run for office Lord people uh I I have
several people that I've had on the show
that I think would be much better
equipped I just don't know that I would
want to be part of that monster I think
I would actually love debating publicly
debating I think I would love the some
of the stuff on being inside the
political system and and really
negotiating of how can we do this and
how can we do that and how do we
actually make things better and can we
talk to people across the aisle and all
that the idea of going through the
monster I don't think it's for me I
think I've out of the goodwill from you
guys and from having some interesting
conversations I think I've been able to
to build something nice here that I want
to kind of see where we can get this but
I would never say never but I did have
Ben Shapiro here and I think he said he
would consider running one day so that
would be that would be something uh
let's see here oh oh this is good
this is on patreon do you see Katie
Hopkins who's
UK author and radio host got reported to
police for responding to the attack
saying we need a quote final solution
she deleted it after but she called for
a true solution in the correction so I
did see some of the like you know the
people screaming about that well look
using the phrase final solution was
probably extremely poorly worded poorly
thought-out or whatever she is a bit of
a flame thrower sort of in the Milo vein
of things so it is possible she was
intentionally saying that but I don't
it doesn't really stand the logic jump
there that she would be making some sort
of analogy there I don't really quite
see it so she may have just wrote
something stupid she may have just some
wrote something stupid she may have been
a being a little cheeky I did I did an
event at University of Texas at Austin
with my friend Faisal Saitama thar a
couple weeks ago and he said something
and it ended with him saying final
solution which then we turned into a
joke so but yes being reported we've
seen as consistently now and even I just
tweeted out something this morning that
what is it the UK something or other
they want people to start reporting more
hate speech so not just direct calls to
violence which everyone is events
against that's a core that's a
legitimate crime if you're calling to
harm or hurt or kill somebody but this
this hate speech thing I mean they're
going to just keep expanding and
expanding and expanding what hate speech
is and then at the same time they're
going to keep deep platforming and
silencing other voices that give you a
counter narrative until the only thing
that will be accepted is the groupthink
of the far left so that's why we have to
be very wary of this thing let's see why
are the coasts mostly liberal and middle
America mostly conservative I'm sure
people have done some interesting
research on this my gut feeling on this
always is that on the coast you have big
cities like really big cities so you've
got New York you've got Los Angeles
you've got Miami
you've got San Francisco and obviously
there's plenty of others but that these
cities are where people from all over
the place kind of gravitate so in
essence they have a live in let live if
you're going to the big place where
you're going to meet all kinds of people
that are different than who you may have
met in the middle of the country or some
other country or whatever
everyone gravitates to this live and let
live place and that's the best of
America
then I think what happens is the the
powers that be in these places which are
usually liberal to progressive left
somewhere in that thing though not
always they then take that that
interesting rich diverse mix of people
and then they they use a lot of state
power cuz you've got so many people oh
i've talked about this before you know
you've got so many people in new york
city living on top of each other from
every part of the world and nobody's
killing each other really I mean people
live yes there are murders in New York
but like everyone lived you go on a
subway and you see everyone from
everywhere and guess what they're not
killing each other but then what's
happened ends up happening is you need
more laws or at least this would be the
argument that you would need more laws
because you have more people with this
different customs and traditions and
whatever so then the state seems to get
bigger always in in small cities while
in a more rural place you can have more
less involvement of the state which
generally falls in line with some
conservative values as for the values
thing I guess also you know if you were
talking about something like gay
marriage for example well if you move to
a city when generally in big cities gay
people move there for more diversity
that then you may become more tolerant
of you know an alternative lifestyle
choice I hate that phrase rather than if
you were in the middle of the country
where you if you weren't around a lot of
gay people it may be it doesn't mean
you're a bigot it just may not mean
anything to you so I think that's so
that's interesting okay super chat what
do you make a trumps arm deal with the
Saudis is there some strategy behind it
so first I'll answer the second part
first yes I think there's some strategy
this idea that the media keeps pushing
that Trump is either some sort of idiot
or has no idea what he's doing or
whatever it's just stupid if he won the
president see without knowing what he
was doing and was just making all these
things up as they happened all that then
what does that say about Clinton what
does that say about the Democrats all
that I don't think much of Clinton or
the Democrats but I just think it's
crazy like there obviously was a plan in
place did Trump write the plan we see
the architect of the plan was it Bannon
was a cushion ER was it pre abyss I
don't know I don't know but I there is
obvious
some sort of plan so what do I make of
look the Saudi American alliance is
insane at many many levels women in
Saudi Arabia cannot drive women in Saudi
Arabia cannot vote there are depending
on the bull in influence of the law they
can't go out without a male guardian
series of other things they throw gay
people off the roof they have public
paintings and beheadings and and all
sorts of terrible stuff there they're
Sunni Wahhabi schools that they're
preaching out there are the people that
then go off to be Isis fighters they
then pay they're paying to build mosques
in Germany and the UK and France and a
whole bunch of other countries where
they're exporting a lot of this ideology
so in and of itself the Alliance that we
have with them is obviously about oil
more than anything else it's about oil
and that right now the Saudis really
hate Iran Trump doesn't like Iran it's
very questionable to me what the deal is
with the Iranian regime by the way
everyone's going crazy about how they
had free elections I mean you know a
couple days ago yesterday it's like I
would temper that down just a bit but
look we've we fund them with a lot of
military equipment they've been in this
war that nobody's hearing about in Yemen
and a ton of people thousands and
thousands of people have been killed now
if that had been if that war in the
Middle East had obviously involved
Israel and or the Palestinians or
whatever else you'd be hearing about it
every day non-stop for some reason the
Saudis can do stuff and we don't hear
about it they obviously have a lot of
money that you know the Saudi prince
owns what 45% of Twitter or something
you know there's so the relationship is
extremely complex I don't really
understand it and I guess you could make
a great argument forget it look we have
plenty of oil here anyway we export more
more than we take I think but if this is
really about oil then we are in some
respects selling our souls and selling
liberalism and and feminism and and
pro-lgbt --za
were selling it for oil with this with
the nature of this relationship all of
that said I thought that Trump's speech
actually was pretty good now again it's
just a speech so it doesn't mean
anything's going to happen but you know
Obama before he became president gave
that big Cairo speech and he sort of
apologized for the way America has been
and and it sort of I think set the world
off on the wrong foot related to foreign
policy and what we were going to be or
not be
and Oh Trump it seems to me is trying to
reset that and he made some interesting
statements he didn't attack religion he
made a point of saying if you care about
young Muslim people and children he
talked about that these non I thought
this was really interesting so he's
talked about none I think he said
non-state actors that are holding a lot
of these people and countries hostage
and he mentioned Hamas and Hezbollah
those are non-state actors that have
taken root that how can you negotiate
with them right so the people of Lebanon
would a lot of them actually do like
Hezbollah but I assume a lot of them
would rather be have free democracy and
all that so anyway I thought he said
some hard truths it didn't strike me as
a bigoted or racist speech again it's
just a speech we don't know what will
happen but it did see that seem like a
lot of opportunity was there like it
seemed like the Saudis were listening it
seemed like yesterday that when he
talked to Netanyahu it seemed like the
Israelis were listening he talked to
Abbas I think today so I haven't seen it
yet but hopefully Abbas was listening
and maybe there is a chance I don't
believe in some grand peace deal that we
can all then live in shangri-la on this
earth I don't think it's the nature of
man to live in some like static thing of
peace but maybe there are ways to make
things a little more peaceful now maybe
maybe we'll see let's see so a lot of
you are asking me basically what can we
do about the discussion about Islam and
I think I've made myself clear I mean it
has to be that I watch my interview with
Yasmine Mohammed from a couple weeks ago
we're sharks about how do you fight this
you fight this with liberalism these are
the ideas we believe live and let live
but that means you have to respect
people let live that these concepts are
the only thing that can that can fight
it so a couple people in patreon asking
do I think the Saudi Arabia is a partner
against Islamic terrorism I mean not
really not really they're funding a lot
of this stuff so it's really hard to
understand exactly what's going on there
and by the way I'm not uh
egotistical enough to think I know
everything about it I don't even think
the government allows the most intimate
reporter to know everything about all
the machinations of the discussions and
all of that so there could be things
going on that we don't know would you
ever get Milo back well I'm a little
annoyed at Milo Milo if you're watching
this Milo was supposed to be on last
week and texted that morning if I'm not
mistaken I think it was that morning huh
to say that he couldn't make it so Milo
what's up Milo yes I'd be happy to talk
to Milo again there's obviously a lot of
stuff to talk about a lot of
controversial stuff and maybe some non
controversial stuff and yes we will get
him back oh this is interesting
what will Arianna do meaning ariana
grande what should she do she has a
chance to change minds for the better to
get red-billed so to speak into red
pillar audience so basically the phrase
red pill in this context meaning like
really understand what's happening here
not pretending that there's no problem
with radical Islam not pretending that
this intersectional oppression Olympic
[ __ ] nonsense leftism ideology this
postmodern drivel and all of this stuff
not to pretend that it works that she
now as a young person that now just
experienced something that is beyond
horrific that she could then take the
mantle and start having a hard
discussion about this because it's
obviously going to be incredibly
personal to her and something that's
going to scar and affect her for the
rest of her life that would be
fascinating if she did if she did step
into that role a little bit I guess I
guess we shall see I would you know when
when the dust settles a little bit maybe
we can try to get her on the show and
I'd be happy to talk about that Dave why
are you being so positive about Trump's
visit to Saudi Arabia it's such a
hypocritical move to think he's going to
help from a top human rights violator
listen nothing I'm saying is in
defensive of Saudi Arabia at all Saudi
Arabia as I said all the things that
they're doing women all the thing
they're doing a gay people virtually no
religious minorities live in Saudi
Arabia anymore they do have roads in
Saudi Arabia that are only for Muslim
people uh Google it if you don't believe
me
um so nothing and again I said they're
sporting all of this Wahhabist craziness
into mosques apart part of Europe the
simple fact is that for what
ever reason and obviously mostly s do
with oil for whatever reason we are
allies with these people so I don't know
what would the better of choice been
Trump to either not have gone on the
trip or just ripped up all of our our
agreements with them I don't know maybe
you can maybe he can move them a little
bit in this regard I also think that the
the threat of terror as it's been
spreading is changing things because
everyone's starting to realize we either
can be for civil you know Western not
even Western civil society or not so
maybe the Saudis are realizing for all
we know Trump went there and privately
said to them you know this is over guys
you're not going to fund any of this
[ __ ] anymore or we are gonna do
something I don't know I just don't know
so I don't think I'm being overly
positive I'm just trying to be somewhat
realistic but if you think I'm wrong
there I respect that I I really do um
let's see uh should I let me jump back
into super chat sorry about all that
uh um Oh has has gift a gun happened yet
if not how do we get Crowder to go
through with it although also your
thoughts on gun control in the NRA
please so gift a gun Crowder was going
to give me a gun steven crowder we just
sort of fell off the map both of us have
been crate you know he moved Studios
just as I was building my studio and we
just kind of got nutty but a hundred
percent I'm down to do it I think it
would be a fascinating thing he did try
one day and I just couldn't do it that
one day we're trying to figure out some
of the logistics but remind him remind
him on the Twitter text them or whatever
and tweet at him and I'm really happy to
do it
as for my thoughts on guns i I just had
an hour ago
Antonio Okafor here who is a really
fascinating woman a young woman who she
runs an organization called empowered
which is about empowering young women on
college campuses to have conceal and
carry on college campuses and be able to
defend themselves I've evolved a bit on
guns I'm a little more pro-gun than I
probably was two years ago I think that
we have a serious mental health problem
that we have to deal with we have to
deal with the I D odd ideological roots
of why people kill people whether it
whether you're killing in the name of
of radical Islam or whether you're
killing in the name of white supremacy
or for any other reason disgruntled
worker or whatever else we have to have
all those conversations but I'll explain
a lot if you watch the interview with
Antonio which should be up
I believe it's next week or might be the
week after there's there's a lot of gun
discussion we did at least a half about
a half about of that Shh I'm this is on
super chat I'm a proud Mancunian the
spread of Mister information on social
media made me truly understand the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
when are you visiting the UK so I can
buy you a drink I will gladly take a
pint from you next time I'm in the UK
I've had a couple speaking offers at a
couple different schools in London so
we're trying to figure it out right now
I've got a whole bunch of travel coming
up which we're going to put a site on
the reuben report calm by the way so you
guys will be able to see where I am in
advance in two weeks it's not a public
event or it's not at a school but I
think it's a public event if you can
still get buy tickets I'll be in
Pittsburgh at Okan which is through the
iron Rand Institute I'll be there with
Fleming Rhodes who's been on the show
and a couple other people Steve Simpson
who I've been traveling around with
doing some free speech stuff and we'll
be talking about free speech and a whole
bunch of other things I'll be doing a
panel and I think some other one-on-one
stuff and moderating something with the
audience and it's just an interesting
cool group of people that's in
Pittsburgh I think I'm there on June
14th but you can okon it's called find
it and and look all right let's see what
else here do you have any plans to do
anything on Turkey and how Iran is
heavily influencing both both the east
and west yeah you know what if you can
think of a really good reporter who
knows a lot about Turkey give me give me
somebody I have a couple people in mind
on this that we've reached out to you
know I've talked to people from the the
Kurdish regional government Bayan Rami
abdul-rahman who have had on is from the
Kurdish regional government I think
she's the US rep to the Kurdish regional
government which so we talked about a
lot of Isis and Turkey and Syria we
talked about that from a Kurdish
perspective but I would like to do more
on Turkey you know Turkey's sort of at
the everyone uses Turkey as well this is
what a modern Muslim nation
look like and they usually say that
meaning meaning on the positive side now
Turkey after Ataturk and there was a ton
of spread of freedom and getting away
from religion and all that stuff and it
was a really secular society it's being
rolled back right now and we know that
that he's firing and imprisoning
professors and all sorts of free
thinking people and it's not going to be
good for the Kurds certainly it's not
going to be good for any other religious
minorities that are there uh and you
know he's also said some crazy things
everyone about that if you don't uh uh
you know if that if the you doesn't bend
to summit turkeys demands related to
certain things that they're gonna flood
the EU with refugees we know that they
let people from Syria come through
Turkey and then go into Europe we know
that Isis fighters from Europe do go
through Turkey and end up in Syria who
the it's a big mess he's been terrible
for democracy and it's again it's one of
those relationships with this giant
country that is it's sort of like Saudi
Arabians respects it's extremely uh
complex and it's hard to know what are
we really getting out of it I don't know
um alright let's see uh please look into
having Michael malice on he's on Joe
Rogan today any minute now and he would
make a great guest for your show I don't
know who he is but usually I find that
Rogan does it Rogan always does a hell
of a job so I absolutely will look into
him Dave do you think that a democratic
pluralist society which tends toward
moral relativism can contend with the
moral conviction and absolutism of Islam
so that's really an interesting question
so the idea that of a pluralistic
society that has people from all walks
of life and different religions and
different sexualities and different
colors and ethnicities and all that
stuff in nationalities that that mix
that postmodern mix of multicultural
stew that used to be a melting pot
meaning that the concept of a melting
pot is uniquely American meaning that
you come here from wherever you are and
you bring your traditions whether
they're Italian or Irish or Jewish or
whatever they are you bring those
traditions here but you become a greater
piece of the American fabric so to speak
right we're bigger than the sum of our
parts uh that's and that's an American
thing that see unfortunately the the
left and this intersectional
nonsense is creating a situation where
integration they're making it hard for
people harder for people to integrate
that if you have a certain haircut
you're now culturally appropriate
somebody that can so the question really
is can that withstand the I want to get
it right because it was good the
absolutism of Islam uh this is the great
fight of our time this is the great
fight of of this generation is that it's
not just that absolutism it's the
absolutism of any ideology that would
any totalitarian ideology that would
come in and that's ironically why the
left is so in bed with Islam because
they're both totalitarian ideologies and
they're using each other the Islamists
and the the Linda Sarsour of the world
are using the the well-meaning feminists
and the well-meaning gay people to
further their agenda that's why the only
solution to this as I said earlier is
classical liberalism it's rooted in the
individual stop judging us all by groups
pretty sure that Martin Luther King guy
didn't want us to be judged by the color
of our skin and it's time to do with the
content of our character that's what can
save us by the way if you're looking at
my hands and they look a little blue I
got new jeans a couple weeks ago and
they're turning my hands blue and I
don't know what to do about it but I've
been walking around blue hands for about
three weeks and I assume it'll stop at
some point but fear not I'm not
suffering from but I'm not suffering
from this is the lair it's Phil DeFranco
says on on super chat love you Dave
what's your favorite thing about Phil
DeFranco he seems super cool and
handsome he's got good hair too that
Phil DeFranco uh Phil if you happen to
be in the area uh you wanna swing by
while doing this live stream let me know
um what am i favor I'll tell you very
obviously what my favorite thing about
Phil DeFranco is is that I did not know
who Phil DeFranco was about a year ago
and suddenly you know how you guys know
how it is on Twitter and social media
suddenly a certain name start bubbling
up popping up this and that
and and suddenly I started hearing a lot
about Phil people saying Dave you got to
talk to him he's an interesting guy he
voted for Gary Johnson he's a
libertarian he's evolving politically
all this stuff and then I watched a
bunch of his old videos and I watched
new ones and I consistently this is I um
if I'm talking to you Phil this is a
little weird but I consistently see
someone who's trying to do something
good that is actually trying to be fair
and decent and not rushed to judge I
once had a tweet that I sent out a
little too early and he kind of called
me out for it and I actually I actually
when I saw that he did I kind of
appreciated it because it wasn't
attacking me or trying to destroy me it
was like ah this is this guy Dave I like
this guy he kind of [ __ ] up here
and it made me want to do better so I
think there's a lot of interesting
people right now and I put Phil at sort
of the top of that list who are trying
to talk to younger people and make some
sense of the world without being a
partisan nut bag and and also he's he's
super cool and handsome and and Phil I I
won't sell yeah when I saw you that day
at that place and you were doing that
thing remember when I saw you there and
walked in I won't tell people what you
were doing all right don't worry about
that okay jump back to patreon and it's
it's 147 so we'll do we'll do about 13
more minutes maybe who knows maybe Phil
DeFranco will walk in while we're doing
this in which case we will extend when
are you going to write a book you've met
so many inspiring people I bet you have
so much to share I am working on a book
I had a bunch of literary agents coming
after me found one that I like uh and
I'm working on it and it will sort of be
loosely based around some of the
conversations I have here with a little
bit of personal stuff more than I just
need a little time for it you know
people say that writing a book is like
the hardest thing in the world and I
just need like the it's not only the the
physical time but I need sort of the
mental space to do it I'm thinking that
I'm gonna try to shut down possibly for
like two weeks in August maybe where I
can take a little time that's not enough
time to write a book but absolutely
something that something's coming you
know what I've been going to these
college events a few that I did with
Steve Simpson from the I Rand Institute
he's got a book uh and I did one with
Michael Shermer he's got a book so
afterwards the kids want me to sign
something I'm signing there other
people's books do doesn't even make
sense all right let's see what else well
we're gonna do a couple more on patreon
and super chat and then we're gonna let
it go um let's see look into having Abby
Martin on the show she does an amazing
series called the Empire files all over
the Middle East and knows so much about
going on over there I'm not a huge fan
of hers personally I've seen her do some
sloppy stuff or stuff that I think is
not that honest but and I think she
attacked me once on Twitter maybe I'm
not sure but anyway yeah I'll look into
it I LeBron that's not a problem on
super chat the hill wrote an article
about the 66 programs that Trump is
making cuts to in his budget what are
your thoughts on this he's supposedly
saving twenty six point seven billion so
I haven't seen the specific article
you're talking about as a general rule
and this is where where that classical
liberalism thing meets the libertarian
thing I'm for the scaling back of the
government meaning you should keep more
of your money so I don't know I can't
comment on the 66 specific things but
generally speaking allowing people to
decide what to do with their money as
opposed to the government and I think
that's a good thing now you might say
well wait a minute if you cut certain
services well then homeless people won't
get food or shelter now I'm a believer
that people will give more when it's
needed but if you have the government
doing anything which often does things
extremely inefficiently and and through
nepotism and all that that it isn't even
done in a very effective way and we know
that a lot of churches and synagogues
and mosques and other social
organizations that they do do charities
effectively this wasn't by the way the
the sort of nexus of the conversation
that I had with mark Duplass about how
what's the role of government when it
comes to charity versus people so I'm
basically for again I don't know the
specifics of this list but I'm basically
for you keeping more of your money and
then you deciding if you want to give
more money you personally Planned
Parenthood great go for it you want to
give more money to your local town so
that the school can give hot lunches or
extend school for an hour to have
you know day care so the parents can be
at work longer or you want to put more
your money so that your locals uh town
can build a basketball hoop okay all of
those things I think those are things
that we can take down to the local level
that that's generally better so I would
be for cutting uh federal programs for
the most part not all of them and I do
think we have to have a social safety
net we have to make sure the people that
need it the most can get some help and
it can't only be left to the private
sector by the way you know we've talked
about a lot about taxes I would be for
not taxing people if they make maybe
under fifty grand or something uh and
give them a break so they can hopefully
move up that's the that's the thing all
right super chat why isn't there more
classical liberals like yourself and
even people on the right like ben
shapiro and larry elder not be oh and
why are people like ben shapiro and
larry elder not being invited onto
left-wing media in more in order to have
more open discussion i mean i mean this
is my life story at this point right
like i am more than happy to have these
conversations with these people by the
way a couple of you know big lefties
that i've invited on lately obviously
bernie and elizabeth warren ban jones
who's who yet he said probably yes on
twitter his people have said no
privately i didn't throw that out there
i don't need to make a big deal about it
gavin newsom i've invited Linda Sarsour
I love her she blocked me on Twitter I
invited the girl from the MTV white
people thing I think I got blocked for
that and a whole bunch of other people
and by the way I continue to have
left-leaning people here the problem is
that unless you're so far left that you
can just grab that mantle of leftism
when I bring decent liberals here people
think they're right wing maniacs and of
course that's nonsense or they just
don't count them as liberals at all so I
wish of course I wish the left would
talk to people like ben shapiro more and
talk like people like larry other people
ask me why i only go on fox news i only
get invited by fox news uh that's it i i
can't just show up to the MSNBC offices
and say guys put me on it's not how it
works
i guess I could try it but I don't think
it's going to work so CNN's not putting
me on the other I don't even care about
any of that mainstream garbage I truly
don't I love what we're
building here and I think it's more
important in a lot of ways it's more
influential but yeah I wish there was
more conversation between both sides
generally right now I think that the
ideas of the left these ideas of
collectivism and this postmodern garbage
there's such bad ideas that they don't
want their ideas challenged which is why
they're in 2d platforming and they're
okay with punching Nazis and all this
other stuff because the ideas don't
stand on themselves so if you can't if
your ideas can't be debated well then
what's the option well let's silence
people or not let them speak at all okay
all right so I'm just seeing this
breaking now so the UK's terror threat
has been raised to critical meaning an
attack as expected eminently Prime
Minister Theresa May is making an
announcement right now and it's
currently unfolding I mean that sounds
horrible generally when they make these
you know if something's gonna happen
right now generally I think things don't
happen fortunately and they're just it's
just an abundance of caution but I don't
know that I can add in anything to that
that's going to make any sense all right
let's see Wow we've got a ton here on
patreon
let's see Dave as a political science
graduate up it ran away from me any
thoughts on recent political events in
France Brazil and the triad Hungary
Poland and Slovenia so on the on the
ladder three Hungary Poland and Selenia
I really want to do more on that and
Eastern Europe I think is probably my
area of least expertise I know a lot
about the Middle East I know a lot about
obviously you know domestic policy I
know a lot about Western Europe and
Eastern Europe really is the least for
me that I would love to get more
educated on if you have some people that
you think would be good in that
department please do let us know and
we'll do a little research on that it's
been something that's been bouncing
around my head anyway
as for what's going on in in France I
mean look McCrone one it sounds like
he's sort of the Clinton Global Asst
Lefty you know the debate was framed
between you know basically like this
this Trudeau style hero and and the
right-wing not see in lepen we'll see I
hope everything is okay in France
they've got a lot of problems right now
um alright okay Crowder apparently you
guys did tweet the Crowder he says that
GiftA gun is really hard in California
but he plans on getting back to me about
it all right Crowder is a man of his
word I have no doubt if he says he's
going to try to do it that he will would
there this is super chat would there be
more of a response to terrorism if the
attacks were more often once everyone
forgets about the last attack a new one
happens what are your thoughts on that
you know that's interesting and when I
would just had Antonia Okafor here we
were talking about that same concept
related to guns that the only time we
want to have the conversation about guns
is when something happens and that there
that's such a dangerous thing because
okay so a shooting happens you've you've
got dead bodies I mean your bodies that
are still warm in some cases we all
start fighting about everything the
people that want to ban guns start
screaming the people that are all about
guns start screaming and and we don't
get anything because when something bad
happens now we've all been were further
pushed off into our corners then when
nothing's happening we don't have
difficult conversations it's why I try
every week to have more philosophical
stuff than do like just the day-to-day
political machinations like turn on CNN
it's mostly dribble most of the people
that you follow on Twitter that are just
tweeting about politics all day long
it's all drivel they're just they just
want clicks the a good government is one
that you don't have to think about that
often so maybe ours isn't that good
because we do seem to have to think
about it a lot but I would like
government to be so small that it can't
affect so much it can protect life and
liberty and it can make sure that we're
safe and that we've got roads and we can
we can discuss all sorts of other
options of that but a good government is
small enough that if it gets taken over
if you think Trump is a secret Russian
agent and you think the Russians have
taken over our government well the best
option isn't burned down the whole damn
system and install king/queen hillary
the the best option is that you should
be fighting to be governed the way we're
supposed to be governed which is by the
Constitution which has three branches of
government which keep each other in
check it's a beautiful system that
pretty much everyone else in the world
is jealous of and we shouldn't just
throw it down the toilet and become
partisan [ __ ] how's that um uh a
hundred ten billion dollar arm deal with
the Saudis goes partially in the hands
of Isis al Qaeda and I'll know
Trump isn't going to defeat terrorism by
arming them yeah I mean I've sort of
addressed this it's unclear to me how
arming Saudi Arabia so that they can
either bomb people in Yemen or export a
lot of this Wahhabi ISM or build mosques
or any of this stuff and why do we keep
this regime white if we believe in human
rights and you believe that women should
be treated equally a bailout to vote to
vote in 2017 to drive in 2017 and you
believe gays shouldn't be thrown off
roofs and you believe that we shouldn't
have public beheadings of apostates and
all this stuff well then it stands to
reason that Saudi Arabia shouldn't be
our ally are there other things going on
there that we're just not privy to I
guess I guess but it's extremely
complicated you know I saw I think it
was Newt Gingrich tweeted something
about how you know this hundred ten
billion dollar deal is going to make all
these American jobs I mean there there
is some truth to that right if they have
to buy military stuff from us then we do
create jobs okay that is one thing but
if we're doing that so that they can
push a lot of backwards maintain control
of an ideology that's going to push a
lot of backwards beliefs then then
there's obviously an inherent problem in
there so I don't think it's a great
alliance unfortunately they have let's
see I think did I do this one or one
more on Saturday as a Jew is great to
see Trump's speech in Saudi Arabia
followed by the Israel trip and speeches
your thoughts on the importance of that
yeah I thought going to Saudi Arabia
laying down some hard truths as I said
earlier I thought that was pretty solid
I don't think the the Israel trip I
don't think there was anything
particularly new there other than that
because the state of the world is so
screwy right now and terror is is
spreading that there could be
opportunity if the sides want to come
together now and see if they can hash
something out I don't have great hope
for that quite honestly but relative to
what Trump said in Saudi Arabia about
getting rid you know these non-state
actors have to be shunned
so Hezbollah in Lebanon and Hamas in
Gaza well these are terror organizations
they don't want to build States they are
terror organizations that want to kill
Hamas they what did they do they took
kill all Jews out of their doctrine and
the left went crazy like you're saying
is
they don't want to kill all the Jews
just have to Jews
yeah that's not great so if we can push
them aside and go alright
is it Abbas I don't know that it's Abbas
Abbas pays where right now I think
Netanyahu said this yesterday but right
now if if the Manchester attack had
happened in Israel and and 22 dead
Israeli children were there
the Palestinian Authority it is in their
law that they pay the family members of
the suicide bomber
so is either quite the right partner for
peace probably not possibly not but at
least there's some Western backing there
maybe it's so complex you toss in a dose
of religion and just ancient hatreds uh
but I do think there may be this is what
I've consistently said about the
trumping everything sort of feels like
it's upside down right now so there's
fertile ground now whether that fertile
ground is going to be is going to be
soiled and and rooted with with terror
and with authoritarianism in
totalitarianism and all that perhaps but
it could also be rooted in liberalism in
Western values in freedom in places
where it will be okay to be a woman or a
gay or a minority or whatever else it is
those are the ideas that we got to keep
pushing out so we'll see ok it's 2
o'clock already so we'll do a bonus five
bonus 5 to my people all right now I'm
being told that members of the armed
forces will be deployed across UK as
part of the raising of UK's terror level
look if unfortunately this may be
becoming the new norm you know I've been
to Israel a couple times and when you're
there yeah there are soldiers on the
streets now other places in Europe and
in Eastern Europe they have this there
are they check your bag when you go into
a mall literally I mean just out of walk
around a little backpack I have a tank
top on and you go to the mall to get
shoes and they go through your bag you
go to the movie theater they go through
your bag they have probably tons of
surveillance cameras and all kinds of
smart profiling and all that stuff this
may unfortunately be the new normal that
we're all heading towards and guess what
the only way that we would be able to
not head to that new normal not head to
a place where every three weeks
something terrible is going to happen
and we're all going to go why did it
happen again and how do we stop it and I
wish there was more love I saw a lot
people tweeting us that we just
a more love in the world it just doesn't
mean anything you're just saying nothing
it makes you feel better I guess for the
10 seconds but it really is nothing what
we need to be doing is having an honest
discussion about the roots of this stuff
have an honest discussion about whatever
it whether its doctrine whether it's
immigration whether it's integration all
of these things whether uh why do why do
we have alliances like we have a
Saturday I mean we could have all these
conversations we got to get better at
having them but we also got a bit what
you can do I think as the average person
because obviously we're not you guys and
myself we're not we're not government
policymakers and all that what we can
all do is start talking about this start
I'm trying I'm just one guy trying to do
this uh but but you guys should be if
you're afraid to talk now we're in the
[ __ ] we are in the [ __ ] and
perhaps we are so there you go let's see
this is interesting from patreon is the
best solution to refuse to accept
religious influence of any type in
political matters and to make it
imperative that any immigrants wanting
to live in the UK or the USA need to
live by its laws well I absolutely do
believe that if you come to the United
States which still more people in the
world want to come to than any other
place on earth you know all these
leftist people that want open borders
they're the same ones to tell you what
an evil patriarchal racist misogynistic
society are we are why would you want
everyone to come here if it's so
horrible here which is just a very easy
way to dispel their [ __ ] I would say
yes absolutely
if you come here I'm we are all
descendants of immigrants okay everyone
here unless your family came over on the
Mayflower or you are the descendants of
African slaves we're all or or you're
Native American every the rest of us are
all descendants of immigrants I think my
great-grandparents on both sides were
were first generation came with nothing
with nothing I don't even know that they
even all had a bag with them the clothes
on their back moved Lower East Side in
New York eventually my grandfather
became a pretty successful importer
exporter he worked with art Vandelay
I hope some of you got that reference my
other grandfather grew up in a tenement
house sleeping with I think six brothers
and sisters
all in one room then he worked really
hard him but it was in a worked at a
printing press and then moved up to sort
of lower middle-class but basically
middle-class in Brooklyn and then my
parents my dad was able to have a
middle-class job and move up the
economic ladder hopefully I'm able to do
that that's the American dream that's
what we all need to do but you can only
do that if you hold the Western values
and and society the things that tie a
society together that's why that melting
pot I talked about earlier is so
important we can still do that we can
sell the goodness of America not because
we want to spread it across the world
although I think that would be nice
ideologically I'm not talking about
spreading it with weapons and missiles
but we can do that right here we have to
reinvent ourselves watch the last five
minutes of my interview last week with
Brigitte Gabriel I mean she nails it on
what freedom really is it doesn't just
you know it's not free it's not free it
was built on the backs of people before
you and if you don't fight for it you
will lose it and we could lose it here I
think people are starting to wake up to
that so so we shall see all right I'm
going to do I'm going to knock out one
more Super chat and and then we'll go
from there finally
okay well this sort of ties it all
together everything we've been talking
about in and Manchester why is it that
mainstream liberal media is afraid to
talk logically about how religion can be
influential after all this they still
don't want to talk about it yeah they
don't and it shows you that that this
stuff with the left that I've been
talking about I'm not just saying it for
the sake of saying it that the this this
ideology has taken root not only and so
much of our politics but in our media
and what happens is when you keep
calling everyone else a bigoted and
racist well then eventually let's say
let's just say that some of these people
that are on these television shows are
well-meaning all these obfuscators and
these people that deny deny logic and
reason also but they are well-meaning
what what happens is they become hostage
to the own [ __ ] that they put out
there so they become hostage to the
ideas that if they start talking about
this stuff now well all the people that
they've been calling racists before well
guess what now all the people that they
tricked into thinking we're racist the
rest of people are doing that are going
to call it on them and nobody wants that
and that's why we have to fight this
thing that's why I talked about the
college stuff people say to me Davey
maybe are you over blowing what's going
on on on college campuses related to
free speech no I've been there I am
talking to college kids who are telling
me they're getting in trouble for using
the wrong gender pronouns girls who were
getting kicked out of feminist clubs
because they talked about that women
shouldn't have to wear the hijab I mean
crazy [ __ ] that is happening and it's
happening in the name of this postmodern
less this junk so I do believe this is
this is absolutely real I'm only telling
you what I think and we gotta fight it
we gotta fight it anyway uh I enjoy
doing these live streams thank you guys
for playing along on super chat thank
you for the support on patreon as always
and you know just catching up real quick
you know there is this issue with
YouTube monetization so for those of you
that do support on patreon or whether
you've given a one-time donation on
PayPal you are keeping the lights on
literally in this case because our
revenue on YouTube was down sixty five
percent last month from the month before
despite comparable numbers and
engagement and our watch times are over
fifteen minutes a video which is insane
on YouTube they should be treating us
like we're the king
this place we don't do clickbait we
don't do misleading titles and tags and
all that other nonsense so I don't do
everything we could for every little
clique
I think we're producing a really
well-done professional show here that
I'm very proud of and I'm very proud of
my team and all that so so those of you
who even if you jumped in and through us
something on super chat here or on paper
our patreon whatever it is you're
keeping the lights on I've gotten offers
as I've mentioned from a couple networks
and I'm able to say no to things because
of you guys because I don't want to say
no I don't want to say yes to something
that it's not something that I really
want to do all right so I've got I've
got another interview in about an hour
I'm going to have a little lunch walk
the dog and stay tuned tomorrow for my
interview with Professor Abbe hall from
Tampa University in Florida really
interesting discussion that we had sort
of bad economics and the police state
and funding Wars and all kinds of other
stuff and I think you're going to dig it
and all right I will talk to you later
okay
you